So now we're going to look at Interdomain
Routing Business Models. So the one thing to
remember about interdomain routing is that it's really
all about routing money. Let's consider this AS
that wants to send traffic to a particular
destination. Well, in the internet there are two
different types of business relationships: a customer-provider business
relationship where money flows from customer to provider,
regardless of the direction that traffic flows, the
other type of business relationship is a peering relationship
where an AS can exchange traffic with another AS
free of charge. This is sometimes also called settlement-free
peering. So already you can see given three possible
ways to reach the destination. This AS is first
going to prefer a route through its customer, because
regardless of the direction of traffic on this link,
money is always flowing from the customer. The
peering link is the second most preferable because it's
free. And the least preferable route is through
the provider, because the AS has to pay money
every time it sends traffic on this link.
This leads to the basic rules of preference in
interdomain routing, where customer routes are preferred over peer
routes, which are in turn preferred over provider routes.
The other consideration that an AS has to make
is filtering, or export decisions. In other words, given
that an AS learns a route from its neighbor,
to whom should it re-advertise that route? To understand filtering
and export decisions, let's add a couple more AS's
to the graph. Let's add another peer, and let's add
another provider. Let's call this AS in the middle
of the picture Cox Communications. This ISP might have smaller
regional customers and it might also buy transit
connectivity from other providers. Now let's suppose that this
AS learns routes to a destination via its customer,
its peer and its provider. Now we already have
established that it would prefer the customer route, so
that it can make money by sending traffic to
that destination. But what about filtering decisions? Well, routes
that are learned from a customer, Cox of course
would want to re-advertise to everyone else, because the
more people use that route, the more money Cox
makes. Therefore a route that's learned from a customer,
gets advertised to everybody else. On the other hand, a
route that's learned from a provider, if it were
actually selected, would of course, only be advertised to customers.
It wouldn't make any sense to take a route
like this and advertise it to another provider. The reason,
of course, is that money is flowing in the
direction of the providers. So any route that's learned from
a provider would never be advertised to another provider,
because it would result in Cox essentially becoming a transit
provider between two of its own providers and paying
them both for the privilege of carrying that traffic. So
routes learned from a provider would only ever be advertised
to other customers. And similarly, routes from peers would only
be advertised to other customers, not to other
peers or other providers. So to summarize, interdomain routing
has both ranking rules, where, given multiple choices,
an AS might prefer a customer route over a
peer route over a provider route. And then,
given that it selected a particular route from either
a customer, a provider, or a peer, Ii makes
different decisions about where to re-advertise that route to
other neighboring ASs. Now as it turns out if
every AS in the internet followed these rules exactly, then
routing stability is guaranteed. Now you might wonder, isn't routing
stability guaranteed already? And it turns out that it isn't.